with the recent release of the asus
transformer pad 300 we've been asked a
lot how it stacks up to the raining
champ of android tablets the asus
transformer prime so basically pretty
much everything that differentiates them
is on the outside not on the inside so
you can see pretty much straight away
that the transformer prime is a bit
thinner than the newcomer it's also a
bit lighter but when you actually hold
it in your hand the prime feels a bit
sharp on the edges while the transformer
pad 300 feels nice and rounded it's a
little thicker it's a bit softer and the
buttons were actually a little bit
easier to press even though they're in
the same spots so i really actually like
the feel of the slightly less expensive
transformer pad 300. the materials just
feel a bit
friendlier maybe that's a weird way to
put it around the back the cameras on
these tablets are both very good for
tablet cameras which is nice and there's
a new plastic back on the 300 which is
less of a fingerprint magnet and has a
new grippy finish to it that i like a
lot as opposed to the solid metal back
on the transformer prime now on to the
front panels we have hardened glass on
the transformer pad 300 here in blue and
gorilla glass on the transformer prime
in red did i notice a difference nope
but there is a slight color reproduction
difference so prime actually has a
slightly more accurate color
reproduction while the 300 in blue tends
to reproduce a slightly cooler colors
with more blue hues but you can't really
notice that when they're not side by
side now in terms of performance you're
going to get nearly the exact same
experience with these two tablets
they're both running that beast of a
quad core nvidia tegra 3 chip the
transformer primes will go a little bit
faster and the gpu is a little bit
faster but really they benchmark within
a few points of each other so the
difference isn't noticeable and if i
didn't tell you which was which you
probably couldn't tell which one seemed
faster because they're nearly identical
in this mark so i'd say the biggest
advantage you have in going with the
cheaper 300 is actually that plastic
back you get absurd wi-fi connection
strength pretty much 100
at all times destroying the metal back
transformer prime and ipad and other
tablets it benchmarked very well with
wireless when the prime has some known
connectivity weaknesses with wi-fi also
just
just so you know the transformer prime
300s dock was better than expected you
can watch my full review of the
transformers dock right here if you want
it provides a lot of useful utility you
know shortcuts it has a sweet track pad
and you get about five hours of extra
battery life just know that the primes
dock does not work with the 300 and vice
versa so make sure you get the right
dock for the tablet that you choose and
yeah i gotta say performance for the 300
for that price which will be in the
description by the way next to that like
button uh is pretty awesome i'm loving
android 4.0 and tegra 3 combo works
really really well and if you're an
android person you know exactly what
we're talking about here i guess i just
have faith in the integra 3 chipset now
the processor is extremely fast and it's
been really successful in other tablets
and in other tegra 3 phones that fifth
companion core makes using the tablet
really smooth the ui just flies and i
guess you could say it's pretty much a
boss
so which one do you get the transformer
prime tf201 or the transformer private
300. well honestly it's a tough decision
there are a couple of main factors that
can make your decision like if you
mostly use your tablet outdoors i'd
suggest a transformer prime it has a
super ips plus display gets really
really bright up to 600 nits and that's
going to be useful for reading it
outdoors if you use it indoors again
it's a toss up if you're flying on a
budget then you're definitely going to
want to consider the transformer pad 300
it's 100 cheaper it's only 399 for the
32 gig and 379 dollars for the 16 gig
and you're definitely gonna get a lot of
value out of it if you're still stuck
between them i would suggest definitely
check out the transformer pad 300
because of the value part of it it's
only right now available in blue by the
way but it's going to be in red white
and blue in the next couple months again
i like the plastic body because of the
ergonomics it's a little bit of an
improved design it's easy nice to hold
and really you can't go wrong with value
on this one but of course for the
android enthusiasts and the spec
enthusiasts out there the biggest thing
you're going to want to wait for is the
third transformer the transformer prime
tf 700t that is a tablet that's going to
bring the overall
combination best of the most world's
experience you're going to get an
updated design you're going to get the
plastic back on the top so you get
better wi-fi and gps you're going to get
the fastest tiger 3 processor that asus
can get in this tablet you're going to
get an awesome design it's just going to
be an amazing tablet so you're still up
to weight 100 more than the prime you're
going to get the tf700t 100 less than
the prime you're going to get the tf300
there you go you have pretty much a full
arsenal of choices there hope this video
was helpful for you guys in choosing
which of the three transformers that you
like for your experience either way
thanks for watching this video and give
a thumbs up on it if you enjoyed it that
really does help out the channel and
help out uh getting the videos out to
people who want to see it thanks for
watching guys talk to you later
peace
you